there you go that's good that's good
kneeling yeah keegan michael key and i
are closing in
on our extraction point but first we've
got to use a diagonal line
to descend the 250-foot icelandic
waterfall that's
it that's it now keep your legs down
legs down
hey have a check out of the seagulls i
bet there'll be sea girls there
there's a baby seagull right there it's
amazing
he doesn't know what the hell i'm doing
here but oh my god
remember don't look down okay okay i'm
gonna start luring you here you go
just me and baby seagulls sitting on the
cliff
look at the power of it well done keegan
good job
almost down last bit
we said we were going to get some place
really fast that was pretty fast
okay trying to go and join him coming
off the waterfall
as i was going down right to the edge
i'm like
what are we doing and the next thing i
know i'm just in midair
but what a view
whoa that was amazing you came down
really fast yeah it was cool i'm glad oh
you got hot gloves
good job thanks man unbelievable yeah
it's amazing unbelievable
i reckon we get around the back of it
look that'd be amazing yeah
so we're at the bottom of this now uh
keegan is pumped
it looks like we might be able to sneak
a little route around the back of the
flow which would be
pretty epic to see wow
there you go that's amazing it's like a
little hidden grotto
yeah exactly i love the sound it makes
it hits the rocks
yeah it's as if it was planned you know
it's completely untouched
so that's nature i've never seen
anything like that
to see the little gulls it's so funny to
watch them like
who is this just but i just i don't know
what it is it's just
communing with another life form yeah
you said something earlier about
you just kind of see yourself nature is
a mirror for yourself
it's really that really that i mean
coming down the side of that cliff
was exciting and exhilarating but seeing
those goals like that was something i
was never expecting to see in my life
you know it was just great that's
amazing it's like for me almost you're
sort of the journey with the
with the weight of the world on your
shoulders and you're finishing it
i love the way it's the little things
like nature and birds and animals that
lifts your spirits what would have
happened if i just said no no
no i can't do that then i wouldn't you
know i would have never seen those goals
yeah what would have happened if i had
said no no you're cool you have the
spider
like just do it keegan what happens if
you just do it yeah you know
where the stuff we fear is often never
as bad once you face it exactly
exactly yeah well that's an inspiring
message and you've lived it more
importantly
right right okay we're pushing on
[Music]
you